USS iwo jima قبالة سواحل
آيسلندا في حظيرة طائرات مشاة البحرية
يستعدون للهجوم الجوي
الانتقامي إذا كان هناك هجوم على حليف الولايات
المتحدة
العريف ديريك هوه المغني هو جزء من
قوة الغزو وضع هذا الحامل ثلاثي القوائم أسفل
وضع المسدس
كما تعلم مستقر  النظام الأساسي لقمع
النيران ، يعتبر التمرين أيضًا رادعًا لأن
منطقة شمال الأطلسي تصبح أكثر
تنازعًا مع هذا التمرين ، حيث تمارس الولايات المتحدة
وحلفاؤها ردهم
في حالة تعرض دولة صديقة للهجوم
بينما يكون الخصم في هذا التمرين
وهميًا ، فإنه يأتي في وقت
تصاعد التوترات بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة وروسيا مع
استعداد قوات المارينز للوصول إلى الساحل الأيسلندي ،
هناك دليل جديد على أن روسيا تعزز
قدراتها في قلب
أوروبا ، حصلت سي إن إن حصريًا على
صور أقمار صناعية من صورة شركة إسرائيلية
سات إنترناشيونال
تظهر على ما يبدو أعمال بناء ضخمة في
روسيا.  قواعد في كالينينغراد ترقية
منشأة تخزين نووي هناك وإضافة
مخابئ ذخيرة جديدة أكبر و
تحديث المطار العسكري هو قيام
فلاديمير بوتين ببناء جيشه
في كالينينغراد ، ولم تستجب وزارة الدفاع الروسية
لطلب CNN للحصول على
معلومات ولكن قائد القوات الأمريكية.
أخبرتني القوات البحرية في أوروبا وإفريقيا أن هناك نمطًا لروسيا تقوم بترقية
قدراتها في المنطقة ، حيث
تضع الكثير من أنظمة الأسلحة الحديثة
، ورادارات صواريخ كروز المضادة للسفن
، ونظام حصن إس -300 و s400 في
إرسالهم.  رسالة قوة إلى
موسكو ، تستعد الولايات المتحدة وحلفاؤها في الناتو
لمناورة أكبر
في النرويج إذا كانوا يريدون تحدينا ،
فسوف نتحدى
أننا لن نخاف من تلك الأنظمة
الموجودة هناك وهذا التحدي  تلعب الآن
في منطقة شمال الأطلسي
مع روسيا
والولايات المتحدة التي تزداد حزما  تبين أنها لن تتراجع عن
فريد يشبه CNN على متن USS iwo jima
في المحيط الأطلسي